hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the four
founders of Hogwarts the group of 10th
Century witches and wizards responsible
for creating the finest School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry the world has
ever seen these witches Wizards were
godric Gryffindor Salazar sutherin
Rowena Ravenclaw and Helga Hufflepuff
specifically we're going to be tackling
the question of why these four Founders
weren't immortalized in some way the
primary purpose of Wizarding portraits
in The Wizarding World is to preserve
the memory of a person long after they
have passed away this ensures that their
knowledge and wisdom can be passed down
to Future Generations but unlike muggle
portraits or photographs which mainly
capture a still image Wizarding
portraits can be animated to capture the
essence of a person's personality often
portraits are enchanted to mimic the
behavior and mannerisms of the portrait
subject objects but there are many
different types of portraits and
animated images in the Wizarding World
so before we move forward any further I
need to quickly Summarize each type this
will allow us to decide which type would
have fit the founders best types of
magical imagery moving photographs are a
type of magical photograph that appear
to come to life and show a brief snippet
of motion unlike Muckle photographs
which are static and unchanging moving
photographs are enchanted to display a
movement or action that's then often
repeated over and over again in a loop
this type of photograph can be found
throughout the Wizarding World including
in the homes of Wizarding families the
offices of the daily prophet and even in
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry they are often used as a means
of communication or as a way to capture
and remember important events or moments
in time one of the most famous examples
of moving photographs in the Harry
Potter series is the daily Prophet which
feature is moving photographs of the
news stories and events it covers these
photographs often add an extra layer of
depth and detail to the stories they
depict as they show the actions and
expressions of the people involved in
the events this type of magical imagery
is most similar to what we have in the
Muggle world and is in no way
interactive or Lively regular portraits
the bulk of the portraits in Harry
Potter are painted by witch or wizard
artists who have used enchantments in
their paint to enable their subjects to
be able to move and interact with the
living this style of portrait accounts
for most of the portraits that hang
throughout Hogwarts Castle it's
important to note however that most of
the portraits hanging around the school
are what JK Rowling has referred to as
two-dimensional meaning they can
interact with the living but only in a
very limited way regardless these
portraits still have a number of
abilities including the ability to move
from frame to frame even frames that
belong to another subject act granting
access to secret passageways and holding
surface level conversations these
interactions provide them with the
opportunity to make use of the phrases
and mannerisms that they were known for
while alive however they cannot offer
quality advice or contribute to in-depth
conversations this brings us to our next
level of portrait Headmasters portraits
Headmasters portraits are far and above
the most advanced form of magical
imagery while at first glance they may
appear to resemble the aforementioned
portraits the difference is it had
Masters portraits are much more
intelligent able to engage in far more
complex conversations and encounters
essentially these portraits are capable
of complex thought and critical thinking
which makes them appear much more
lifelike according to JK Rowling the
type of portrait typically corresponds
to the power and abilities of the witch
or wizard who was featured in the
painting this suggests that the more
powerful witch or wizard was in life the
more life like their portrait stands to
be this would explain why Dumbledore's
had Master portrait is so capable of
in-depth conversation advising Severus
from his frame well after his death
Dumbledore was one of the most powerful
Wizards to have ever lived so it stands
to reason that his portrait would have
been one of the most sentient but there
is actually more to it than that as it
turns out edmaster's portraits are
painted well before their deaths kept
away in hidden locations where owning
their living counterparts are able to
interact with them the subjects would
then visit their paintings as often as
possible imparting memories and wisdom
onto them basically teaching the
paintings how to be them through this
process they are able to become very
good representations of these witches
and wizards however it is also important
to remember that they cannot grow or
learn from future interactions or events
in the same way that someone like a
ghost could rather the head teacher
portraits are more like the sentient
Memoir of each Professor able to respond
and provide advice to People based on
the memories and wisdom imparted onto
them before the real witch or wizard
died Hogwarts Headmasters are an
integral part of Hogwarts history and so
it makes sense that their portraits
would be immortalized in this very
special way however I would argue that
the Hogwarts Founders are an even more
important part of the school's history
so the question remains why didn't they
get portraits why weren't they
immortalized I think the Founder's
portraits would fit just perfectly at
the entrance to each common room or
perhaps even in a row overlooking the
Great Hall it also occurred to me that
the portrait of the founders could
potentially Aid in the Sorting ceremony
I've got a few theories one they didn't
want portraits didn't bother it's
entirely possible that even though they
deserve them the founders of Hogwarts
simply didn't want their portraits to be
displayed this could have been for any
number of reasons though I suspect that
it could be linked with concerns
pertaining to how their legacy may be
portrayed by Future Generations
it's also possible that the founders may
have had a disagreement or falling out
before they died resulting in them not
wanting their portraits to be displayed
together it's also just possible that
they simply didn't bother making
portraits because they had other things
to do these four witches and wizards
were focused on establishing the
groundwork for the finest institution of
Witchcraft and Wizardry in the world so
I'm sure that they had more than enough
on their plates already two they were
too humble this one sort of ties into
the last point and it explores the idea
that the founders shied away from
portraits due to humbleness their names
were already on the four Hogwarts houses
so it's entirely possible that the
founders may have viewed portraits as a
step too far perhaps they avoided them
as to not appear egotistical or
self-absorbed additionally I suspect
that they may have also been aware of
the fact that if their portraits were
hanging in the Halls then their presence
may have overshadowed the current
headmistress or Headmaster
3. they exist in a hidden location it's
entirely possible that they found its
portraits do actually exist they're just
hidden off in some secret compartment
within the school Hogwarts is riddled
with secret rooms and Chambers so to me
this idea is not too far-fetched before
they didn't have the knowledge another
possibility is that the founders of
Hogwarts did not have the same level of
magical knowledge as later generations
and were unable to create their own
portraits I'm sure they were incredibly
powerful but it's entirely possible that
the creation of magical portraits is a
more recent development five they were
destroyed lost it's entirely possible
that at one time the founders did in
fact have their own portraits but that
over the course of time these portraits
became damaged or lost Hogwarts has been
around for over a thousand years which
presents an awful lot of opportunities
for things to go missing get damaged
6. dark intense another reason that the
founders may have opted not to have
portraits is that they may have been
concerned about the potential for their
portraits to be used for dark magic in
the Wizarding World portraits can
sometimes have a life of their own and
can be manipulated by others perhaps the
founders did not want to risk their
portraits being used for nefarious
purposes and as a result chose not to
create them and that's it for this video
do you want more videos covering the
Hogwarts portraits something else do you
agree with my theories leave a comment
down below until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live